What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And today we are back with another gun game
This time we have 21 different sports equipment
And after each point
The items will get harder
Let's go!
0-0
Short spin!
I think you didn't see that coming
Okay, time for the dart board!
So close!
Oh you have a different tactique
That looked very risky!
No!
Two in a row!
Disc
With this racket you should be able to...
Put the shots in!
I'm not going to do the skating intro like Otto
It looked too dangerous!
Next up
Wow, not those yet
Cricket bat!
It was like a short put
I will go with this one
This feels like a bazooka
Yeah, this is becoming a real gun game!
You are never getting rid of the skateboard!
No, probably not!
I think I'll take the left-handed boxing glove
Let's go!
Okay, Rocky!
Just have to play safe and make Otto move
That's how I win
I'm going to play safe too!
Finally I get rid of this one!
Well, that was a K.O. (knock out)!
Are you trying to scare me with that?
Yes
No... that was like my racket twiddling
It didn't work!
Time for some squash!
How is my squash technique?
Taking use of my chopping exercises
Yeah, that's looking good
Look at that footwork
Quite slick
Thanks!
I have to say I like this!
This is my favorite item so far
Time for the boomerang
Oh you are chopping with that also?
I am!
Apparently Emil likes to chop with everything
Now I'm not going to miss
Me neither
It's going to be a long rally
It's not the heaviest
But it's not the lightest
16 kg
I so love a good workout!
Yeah I can't get that one
A volleyball!
I knew that I would win when I got it on table!
Otto rate the technique
Beginner minus minus!
Master plus plus!
Feels like I'm doing all the work here
I mean this is for once...
I'm going to win this!
This is how it feels to be Otto in table tennis
You just stand there and let the opponent do all the work!
Like this!
It hit the GoPro!
I think the official rules say that
"You lose the point if you hit the GoPro."
So I can get rid of this now
Boxing bag!
Maybe this is the right tactic
Surprisingly good shots
I was trying to hit as hard as I could but
the ball didn't really go anywhere
Okay, this is going to be extremely interesting!
So slow!
It looked like I didn't even try
but there was nothing you could do
It's so slow!
I can get rid of this
Next up is this
Swimming thing
Let's go!
What did you say Otto?
I said:
What?
"Subscribe to Pongfinity"
Okay, I got it!
I'm so relieved!
I'm not going to miss that again
Next up we have the yoga mat
I think the official rules say that:
"You can't have the ball on the racket for 15 seconds."
See, I found it!
Now it feels like normal again for me to play like this
Go on, go on!
Go on!
Last one!
One more!
Stop it!
Nice work Emil, you fought well!
Next up for me, ab roller!
I'm going to try a new tactic
The bike helmet
I think I'm going to ditch the foot tactic
Now I really need to think how to play with this
Good try Otto!
Now I go with this
He actually got one shot!
I really don't know what I was thinking there
I didn't try it that far...
But I'll take it!
You went for the hard core shot!
Good slingshot!
Time for the ski pole
Good one
The "cmon" didn't work this time
It worked for you!
You took it from me!
Darts!
This is my big chance to beat the Sensei
Sudden death
And that's the game and match!
Thank you! Good match!
There's still a lot of you guys
who haven't subscribed to our channel
so help us our and do it now!
Until next time!
One of the hardest items
This is yeah
It's even way harder than the pen